hello and welcome to the damned episode
of the weekly google glass on podcast i
am francisc and i'm here with mark Mike
Mendell how are you doing I'm good he
doing French desk right yeah pretty good
just getting very excited about this
episode we're gonna be talking with some
more good friends google developer
expert some good friends in Australia
yeah makes me very happy so we're gonna
be interviewing them about GD what is a
google developer expert what they do and
how do you become one yeah and even talk
a little bit more about big data and
some of our tooling in that area to and
how some of our actual users are using
it and you have these cases they have
stats yeah that's that's really the kind
of people are really enjoyed talking to
is people that are using our
technologies for things that we didn't
not even expect yeah because that's how
you learn how to improve your products
really so yeah very very useful people
definitely and if anyone's out there
using our products and want to come on
the podcast please don't hesitate to get
in contact with low yeah week to you yep
should we do should we do the do the
back method what's the email address the
email address is hello gcp podcast come
on reddit it's the subreddit / odna r /
gz podcast on twitter at gcb podcast the
website JC podcaster come and google+
plus gcb podcast Plus Google cloud
platform podcast you can actually get to
you can actually get google com plus GC
phuket podcast oh there you go okay yeah
I almost got it this time there we go
ahead so yeah if you have any like let's
do it again if someone wants to send us
emails about cool things of the week
questions or topics that you could like
us to cover whatever we always like
receiving emails from you people yeah it
makes this job fun so we definitely want
to hear it yeah wonderful so we have we
have a great cool thing in the week this
week I'm pretty excited about this one
it's yeah been much I'm between excited
and slightly scared cuz a lot of work
coming on better so yeah we're gonna be
we actually just announced the next gcp
next so just the next gcp next tuesday
next yeah that's good way of putting it
gcp next which is the Google cloud
platform big event taking place in San
Francisco pier 48 if i'm not mistaken
and it's gonna be on march twenty-third
and twenty-fourth yes it is so what is
this about so it's the big google cloud
platform event so if you're interested
in google cloud platform and you want to
come down and meet the DA's make the
developer advocates make the engineers
i'm sure they're probably also just as
exciting product managers yeah here
probably I'm guessing they're gonna be
some exciting announcements I can
confirm nothing yeah there's completely
confidential things like majesty now it
is gonna be really cool stuff I know I'm
very excited about about the keynotes
also because we can have some really
cool people are the keynote we have
Earth's gonna be speaking nice also they
am so yeah basically the line Stevens
Ryan seven so the top people go club bad
for my gonna be there for you um so I
think it's an opportunity not to miss
Jeff teens gonna be there yeah yeah Jeff
Dean yeah he's gonna important yeah I
guess a little bit smidge you know yes
I'm but um yeah we're gonna be lying
like a gcp boot camp the day before as
well so full there instructor-led
training really like yeah we'll
definitely have the link in the show
notes but if you have anything
interesting you want to hear about
Google cloud platform and you want to
sort of mingle with people who are also
doing Google cloud platform things do
you speak next is the event to get to
know I know I'm gonna be there actually
we're gonna be there we're planning on
recording a special episode our first
episode outside of the studio yeah yeah
so if you're interested in being in the
podcast but I want to like do a little
work if you're physically at the event
we will be around and we'll be looking
to interview people at the event so
please definitely come up to us and say
hello yeah cool okay so that was our
cool thing of the week now I guess time
to go say hi to our friends in Australia
let's talk to her friends in Australia
we are joined today by the very first
google developer experts to be coming on
air with us on the podcast i'm very
excited also because both of them live
in my hometown of melbourne australia
which makes me doubles excited
we are joined today by Graham holy and
public cave which I think I just messed
up your last yeah it's a bunch of guys
both of you how do you pronounce your
last name so that people know how to get
them right it's case it is it speak
Spanish is his in Spanish it's easy
Holly course and it's my voice is that
it's probably hasn't Polly wants a
cracker yeah I didn't even worse as I
asked you before hand and then mess it
up in exactly the yeah thank you thank
you so much for joining us um like I
said oh you're both Google developer
experts and open the program for a
little while you're both down in
melbourne australia which makes me super
happy any meenie miney moe Graham you
are on our document first why don't you
give us a little bit of background about
yourself you know who you are what you
do I'm we'll get to Pablo sure so first
of all thanks for having us to the
podcast we're also very excited to do it
and my name is Graham Polly I'm a
software engineer and also a google
developer expert as you've pointed out
already and I'm actually a google
developer expert for cloud platform and
I specialize in Big Data so work a lot
with tools like bigquery cloud dataflow
data proc Google Cloud storage and also
yeah the usual compute engine type
things as well and based on the
Melbourne nice what about your problem
yeah so I'm also very happy to be here
and I'm a google developer expert same
as brown for the Google cloud platform
and software engineers well been working
in the field for or something like us 13
years done off a few things like mobile
development web development but la
living mostly specializing in big data
and all the sort of stuff nice you are
google developer expert school you tell
us a little bit first of all for how
long and how you became a google
developer experts but also what what is
it what is being a google developer
expert maybe Brian can start
sure yeah sure so and both myself and
Pablo we came on board as google
developer experts are in the same time
actually at the same time that would
have been about three months ago now so
we're fairly new to the program and what
it means is we're recognized by Google
there is about I believe 250 of us
worldwide so we're recognized for our
expertise in a specific area of Google
technologies their products in our case
it's google cloud platform we do a lot
of blogging we go and talk at
conferences we help the local community
we have start-ups we do mentoring and we
also get a yearly trip once it once a
year we get to meet all the other Google
developer experts which is really cool
this year it was in Mountain View just
in last month which is really cool yep I
saw you guys there yeah we get direct
access to the engineering teams as well
so we get early access to build and
features and new products and stuff like
that and we can reach out directly to
the engineering teams and that's that's
a huge help for especially when we're
using the products we can talk to the
engineering need teams directly it's
it's awesome and we also get four side
into product roadmaps and that kind of
thing so that's being a google developer
expert and then the journey about how we
actually became google developer expert
says it's quite an interesting one so
myself and pablo we were doing a lot of
work with bigquery and we were just
blown away by how cool it was and how
much data we could smash through and we
wrote a blog about it and that blog got
picked up by our good friend Felipe
Hoffa who I believe you guys know quite
well yes yeah we interviewed him two
episodes ago yes ah two episodes ago
yeah cool so yeah Felipe's great guy and
he actually picked up our blog he found
our blog and he shared it internally and
then it actually went it made its way up
to earth wholesaler who then we shared
it on his G+ page and then from there it
just kind of snowballs and then we
started doing more blogs and then what
actually happened was the data flow team
so Google Cloud dataflow team
doubt was and he said look we got this
new product in beta it's called cloud
dataflow we think it would be pretty
cool for you guys to be beta testers on
it so we said yeah absolutely it's and
we jumped in we started playing with it
we gave them feedback and then after
that the product manager for Google
Cloud dataflow a guy called Raphael
Fernandes he then nominated us to become
Google developer experts and that's the
key to being a google developer expert
you have to be nominated by a Google
employee so once you're nominated by
Google employee then you do an
application so myself and Pablo did that
and then you go through a round of
interviews they make sure you really
know what you're doing and you really
know what you're talking about and then
you finally get accepted to the program
and that's pretty much the journey of
how we became Google developer experts
nice so Pablo you've been relatively
quiet why don't you tell us a little bit
about the work you do is shine and the
tools you use and how they go together
and what you're up to yeah so first of
all shiny say software consultancy based
in Melbourne and we do a lot of work
with a big data so we our on one of our
main client is a Telstra yeah it's it is
one of the largest ISP and it will talk
a little bit later about more in depth
about the stuff we do in there but
basically you know we need to anchor in
chess tons and tons of ad serving logs
and process them we use a whole
combination of stuff between the you
know Google cloud platform tools and a
bit of AWS as well basically the idea is
to help them to understand the all the
data they using the basically get like
useful insights to all the information
they have that's very cool that's very
cool so I think one of the highlights
for me when actually I probably got to
know you and Graham from shan technology
and stuff was the blog post about the
17-minute train challenge oh yes was
quite exciting do you want to tell
listeners a little bit about that and
how that came to be and I mean even like
where did that idea even come from
yeah sure so I was actually so my I take
the train to work and I was sitting on
the train coming in I was reading as you
do yeah the tech news and something
popped up in my feet and it was google
have announced a new product called data
proc I window that looks kind of cool so
I started reading about it and I was
actually chatting with Pablo at the same
time I am and we just got talking about
it and then one of the things in the
announcement i think was on the Google
cloud platform blog it was we can spin
up a Hadoop or spark cluster in under 90
seconds I taught wow that's that's a
bold claim that's a really bold claim
and we got to thinking and we thought
let's vet that let's see if it really
can't do that so we came up with the
idea of could we actually spin up a
Hadoop / spark cluster using data proc
in the time it takes for my train to the
part melbourne city and get home to my
last stop but not only that so we
thought that was a little bit easy we
also true a few other curve balls into
the mix so it would have to spin up the
cluster and so my train commute is 17
minutes so it would have to spin up the
closer it would have to be able to run a
Hadoop job it would have to be able to
run an Apache smart job and I should
also be able to ssh into some of the
nodes in the cluster and have a play
with them and use the cloud shell from
the browser and all that kind of stuff
and then finally tear down or the whole
cluster before the train got into the
last station so that's really how the
idea came about it was just 7 Pablo were
chatting about her we taught to be
really cool something original and it
would actually be a good way to see if
data proc really was that fast it could
have really stand up a cluster quickly
and so we did it and
the one of the great things about it is
actually we just chatted it off my phone
so we stood up the data broke cluster I
can't remember I think it was eight
nodes in the cluster or something like
that all chattering off 4g it's crazy so
I see here ice to see here that you
didn't quite complete the challenge
you're very close though got very very
close so I was pulling into the last
station and I initiated a shutdown of
the cluster and unfortunately the closer
just didn't shut down in time so I got
to spin it up I got to run a Hadoop job
I got to run a spark job SSH into some
of the nodes but the cluster just didn't
come down in the time it needed before I
got home but I marked it down as a as a
success so so it was deleting it was it
was in the person it was in the process
of the leading exactly i think i missed
it by about 30 seconds that was very
good seriously so yeah was it recorded I
could have loved to see that as a video
of seeing you panic in trying to stop a
bit closer by before the trains arriving
to the station unfortunately yeah so
unfortunately it wasn't recorded didn't
have the foresight for that one did do a
blog post about it so you're more than
welcome to read the blog and it's got
screenshots in there and it was a very
Eber scientific challenge as you can
tell jump on a train tetra phone spindle
fit the data pro cluster but one of the
things that I fail to consider or that
we fail to consider before we did it was
but there's black spots on the track
yeah 4d so every now and then I'd lose
my connection and I'd lose my ssh
session and like panic panic panic until
the my connectivity came back and then
yeah but it was good fun it was good fun
it's something and it again it was the
originality of it as well and the blog
post got quite a lot of attention and I
think it got shared again internally at
Google so it's really cool and that
leads into the google developer expert
stuff that's the kind of stuff we do as
well you know writing blog posts like
that ya know you were saying there's not
a very scientific method of comparing
performance i actually
I have this video that i really like of
one of the people from the Cooper net
esteem Brendan Byrnes trying to measure
how long it takes to start up a
kubernetes cluster and comparing it to
how long it takes for him to prepare a
latte oh so you know it sounds like a
lot of fun yeah Oh Miley terrific entire
dolly sanctity of course good alright
cool so and obviously you're doing stuff
we like data pro can you drink stuff
we've big data and bigquery you want to
talk a bit more about the sort of big
data problems you're working on
obviously you said you were talking
about analytics and stuff like that but
can you talk a bit more more concretely
about the stuff that you're building and
why you chose Google cloud platform in
the tools you have to solve those
problems here so I mentioned before we
we basically dealing with tons and tons
of at seven locks what we have come to
you know work on is day basically in a
statistical model that analyze all those
logs which is developed by a veteran
data scientist and that's the main beat
we actually you know started using a
data flow for all the sort of an ETL
work and actually the actual statistical
model implementation each one of the
steps and we found that it was very
helpful in that aspect and we also use
bigquery of course to store all this a
huge amount of data and we can run a
hook at queries pretty quickly like go
through terabytes of that ina in the
matter of seconds which I remember the
beginning let left a few people very
very a Dornish about all this stuff like
they were wow I can believe you you can
really tell me you're telling me you can
actually run like query like terabytes
of that I in 15 seconds yeah but with
Oracle it takes like you know no one
hour you know and then when they were
seeing the real at all I can't believe
this so I'm curious what's the largest
data set that you've put through
bigquery so yeah so I think the the
amount of data that we have up with
Telstra pubs is what we have so we're
doing about 5 billion rows a month
that's what we were ingesting into
bigquery is that right Pablo by five
billion rows a month and then we've run
queries over several years so we've gone
up to about it about a hundred billion
rows and it was about 15 terabytes yeah
it's difficult because we got a several
projects going on so you said ever need
to you know get on all of them and yeah
but I think something like that so for
us is quite a lot of data cool a lot
better cool and so what sort of what
sort of things are you providing for the
customers obviously it's like
statistical models and stuff is that
you're helping them with things as yeah
so basically we we have implemented all
these statistical model then they use
like bi tools to access to that so we
owe the results of run in the model gets
dumped into bigquery and and we also
been trying to help them lately it to
understand how a data flow works because
you know it's so what's good for them to
get a very good understanding of how
they can optimize the algorithms so they
can work much better you know in this
end dataflow programming model m and we
also been given a few technical talks
about bigquery and data flow you know to
help them understand the advantages you
can get when using the Google cloud
platform products oh it seems like
you've basically been working on on big
data for quite a while and you've been
blogging about it and thanks to just
blogging you ended up becoming one of
our td's what is your advice for other
people that want to become a GD yeah
that's a really good question so
I would say it's a very good program and
at least I can speak for myself and say
I'm happy in the program and what I like
most about it like I touched on earlier
would be getting direct access to the
engineering teams that's just awesome
like last month we were over in San
Francisco attending the gde summit which
is that yearly event that I talked about
where we all come together for a year
for a couple of days but around that we
actually went out and we met the myself
and Pablo went and met all the data flow
engineering teams and we SAT with them
and we discussed how we use the tool and
the product and that was really cool and
they actually SAT with us and they
actually did a code review so the tech
lead for data flow reviewed our code
Frances Perry that was just those
unparalleled in terms of awesomeness and
she was like yeah you could do some
optimization here and performance
enhancer deer and change this and it'd
be a little bit more modular we were
like oh my god trying to actually code
while she was telling us this stuff and
then after that we went up and we met
the Dremel and bigquery engineering
teams in Seattle like that's just cool
right where you can sit with these guys
and talk to them and and talk to
engineers being engineers ourselves
about how these tools work they don't
give up all the juicy details of course
although for example the Dremel works
under the hood but we were privy to some
some information that not a lot of
people would get and that's one thing I
I particularly like about the program
and the second part how do people get
into the program is they are interested
it would it would really be getting your
name out there so start off doing
blogging go to your local GDG group in
your city so most cities will have a GD
g which is google developer group and
let's officially sponsored by google
going to the meetups chatting with the
guys and girls at those meetups and then
if you're really really keen to get into
the program you really gotta make that
connection with someone in google or be
nominated that's the only way
to get in I think that's it's a good
system because that's the way Google
really get good people in its if you're
nominated so yet my advice would be just
to get publicity to get your name at
their blogging doing talks because like
you don't have to be a gde to go ahead
and do this stuff you can go ahead and
do this stuff without being a gde right
so you can give a talk at a local meetup
or you can write a blog on bigquery or
kooban a days or data flow or data proc
you don't have to be a gde and then that
will if it's a good blog and it's got
good content I'm sure it'll be picked up
by someone and that's how it all at
least that's how it started for us so I
hope that I hope that answers your
question yeah it sounds like a very good
advice I had not thought about the about
google developer group yeah that's a
great place to start yeah that's the
that would be the first place I'd star
yes so for me again it's pretty much
pretty similar to what grandpa said
before in terms of meeting the engineers
for me was the the top of the you know
they tear the cherry and the on the pie
and it was really exciting a you know
get to talk to them to the people who
actually have been developing the tools
we used know them from top to bottom I
was very privileged to have also the
deleted Francis berry reviewing my slide
deck I was giving a talk in the DEP fest
and she SAT with me we went through all
the slide deck she's you know start give
me recommendations about how to you know
present different things and stuff like
that and for me that was really really
excited and it was a privilege to answer
the second part of the question I know
this pretty much were also gran said in
terms of if you really cannot get into
the you know the expert program you need
to make visible yourself in terms of you
know writing blogs or participating in
Google developer groups giving talks if
you can that's always good you know
trying to present stuff talk about the
technology it sounds good excellent
alright wrap up soon but is there
anything else you wanted to maybe
discuss or
bring up or plugged or anything like
that um check out our blog will put the
link on the show notes yes for sure
definitely beautiful and Pablo um you
mentioned that it was important to be
out there give dogs go to conferences
where can we find you are you going to
any conference in yet we applied for a
few talks there's one coming up in
London big data at the moment hasn't
been confirmed yet there is also the
coming Google cloud platform event and
now in march in some from we also apply
for that one but we also you know give
some talks in the local developer groups
so i myself giving a talk in the end of
februari about data flow in the GDG
group here in melbourne I think we can
add the details about the event in the
notes definitely Graham was there
anything else and no than just the usual
stuff Twitter myself and Pablo are
really active on Twitter we we have some
pretty cool conversations with people
like Felipe and Francis and all those
guys in the US so you can you can get us
on Twitter anytime and I'm sure my
twitter handle will be made public and
Pablo's too yes like Pablo said we've
got a few talks talk proposals in the
pipeline one of the biggest one that I'm
most excited about which Pablo just
touch would be the gcp next and that's
in in March now unfortunately I've got a
baby on the way on the exacts do you do
date is the exact same day so it's the
march twenty third Pablo will be heading
over to that and hopefully what
congratulations on that by the way yeah
there's gonna be a first baby so and the
storm is about to arrive at my doorstep
in about nine nine weeks so fingers
crossed that would be really cool if we
actually got to speak at gcp next which
is we have no control over that other
provider I wasn't people who may listen
to the podcast malice
may have been told that's not what I was
hinting at at all in any way whatsoever
so what would be what will be will be
wonderful well thank you very much for
joining us I think we're gonna have to
wrap it up there for time sake I'm sure
we could talk for hours on end but yeah
thanks very much for joining us it's
been an absolute pleasure thank you very
much thank you very much and yeah
likewise thank you very much looking
forward to reading your future blog
posts in davia well we'll talk to maybe
then but thanks again to Graham and
Pablo for joining us really good
conversation enjoy getting outside of
Google people to come in and speak it's
always great fun yeah that was that was
very fun conversation yep so moving on
to the question of the week france asked
i believe you have a question today I do
have a question it's actually coming
from a couple people that I've met
before there's a lot of people that try
to do things like integration tests or
even continuous integration what you're
trying to do is to deploy continuously
yep and decline continuously it's pretty
hard there is ways of doing it but you
know this is skill there then there's
deploying continuously to App Engine oh
yeah and all of a sudden doesn't sound
that is anymore because you have to use
g-cloud and there's a bunch of all you
have to integrate authentication and so
on so the question was like is there an
easy way to do deployments to App Engine
like say programmatically remark yeah as
part of the script something that's
gonna be happening very regularly so uh
I got shown this not too long ago and I
found it quite exciting there is an API
that we have that enables you to
programmatically deploy to App Engine
nice it's it's really cool it's both a
REST API and a grp capi so you have a
choice if you want to you want to twitch
ever one you want to use it's pretty
cool you can upload your content like so
basically your resources up into Google
Cloud storage you send up a JSON
manifest file to tell App Engine hey
this is where my stuff is this is how I
want to deploy it this is where I wanted
to go and then it goes off and does its
thing and then there's also stuff in
there for like switching module so which
like which modules you want to go to and
like also doing Lee your standard
versioning stuff too yep I
fifty percent of my traffic to go to
this one or ten percent or a hundred
percent yeah and like also introspection
you can also do introspection through it
to like what if i got running what
versions do I have what apps do I have
it's pretty neat i was actually really
impressed with it so if you're looking
at doing like continuous delivery type
of stuff you want to be able to push to
App Engine this looks like like a really
good way of doing it yeah that's nice
very good I could definitely see it as
some something integrate the early with
Jenkins or Travis or something mad so
basically as soon as you have a new file
that has changed everything you get a
bunch of tests gets deployed somewhere
and then someone can't just go and
verify that everything is working so i'm
actually thinking we should do this for
the podcast because right now every
wednesday we manually push it up if we
had a service that built it push it up
the App Engine every Wednesday like it
like 10am auras are you proposing using
Google technologies to house the wolf up
at home podcast yes I am busy this would
actually make make my life a lot easier
rather than getting up at seven-thirty
every wednesday to push out of focus
yeah I'm not waking up ya know that
sounds that sounds like a good idea
which we should try it an open source
the course of course of course wonderful
alright that sounds great well Francesca
if you got anything else on your radar
obviously gcp next will be coming up for
you so just be next is coming on soon
but before that I actually have a bunch
of stuff going on uh so by the end of
this week i will go to Belgium yeah
awesome there's gonna be a gold Ephraim
so if you're around come say hi uh it's
gonna be fun i'm gonna be talking about
the state of go so what is the gold
project doing lately yep gonna be a
quite interesting talk a bunch of new
things in the language not really in the
language for in the tooling so i hope
that there's going to be a bunch of
people there we're gonna have nice
conversations after that def fest in
Paris nice where I'm gonna be talking
about gr pc and korean ideas and
building I think that the name of the
talk maybe at the end building
microservices like a rumor oh yeah I
think we need to get your pc on here I'm
getting really excited about that we
should definitely talk about grp see we
actually just mentioned that yeah we
have like our PC references yeah for the
mean API yeah we should definitely talk
about that maybe next episode many
smokes and that's pretty much it i think
for now like that's in the next month
but isn't it yeah yeah that's what about
you so i will be at the launch hackathon
on the 26 of februari where is that it's
in san francisco which is good yeah not
doing too much trouble at the moment
which is nice so I'll be helping people
hack at that and probably getting no
sleep very excited about Game Developers
Conference i'll be there at the booth
pretty much all the time we're looking
at doing some really fun events were
having a developer day for that so if
you're interesting google cloud platform
please check that out we doing all sorts
of fun things but we'll also be doing
some talks sort of at the booth as well
showing off a few bits and pieces we got
i think we might see some of our demos
which would be really cool nice but yeah
I love games so I'm super excited back I
know I was I was last year at GBC it was
an amazing conference so really good
forward to the gym yeah it's gonna be
great just be next obviously I'll be
there as well and then i'll also be at
strata helped us with some stuff there
too so that'll be good fun very nice
well i think that is enough for today
definitely so as always thank you so
much for being here with me thank you
very much for being here with me and
talk to you all next week see you next
week
you